so we're going to talk about a condition
called PC OS or PC OD the same thing
polycystic ovarian syndrome or disorder
okay now we're going to talk about the
cause and effect if you look this up
you're not going to find a lot of causes
it's always going to say unknown it's
related to insulin resistance it's hi
energons blah blah blah but let's take a
look at what is the cause and the root
cause the reason why it's hard to find
out about this is just because of how
its named poly means many cystic means
cysts in reality PCOS is not really
cysts it's follicles which follicles are
eggs released by the ovary so in other
words the ovary is producing too many
follicles so what happens this should be
really named poly follicular ovarian
syndrome but it's not but here's the
relationship there's a little sac around
this egg that makes an urgent sand in
the body what's normally supposed to
happen and these Andrews antigens are
supposed to be converted into estrogen
okay
via ins on and what happens that this
enzyme is blocked in any shape or form
you're going to get a buildup of
androgens so this entire kind of a
pathway gets blocked it's kind of like a
chain of events they're supposed to
occur if you block this chain right here
everything kind of backs up so it's like
you're constipated because your your
colon is blocked you're going to back up
through the plumbing and to the liver
well this is what happens hi antigens
come from the block of that enzyme and
if you look up things that block this
enzyme and if there's any medical
doctors or physicians the name of this
enzymes called aromatized cytochrome
p450 which basically also helps you
detoxify toxic chemicals in the liver so
this specific chemical blocks the enzyme
and causes high energons this chemical
glyphosate is an herbicide it's made
by Monsanto and it's another name form
is called roundup and it's in a lot of
the GML food so if you want more data on
that watch my GMO video but this
chemical which is in so many foods not
just plant-based but also animal-based
because animals are fed this GMO food
you're getting exposed to a lot of this
chemical right here which will block
this thing up and Spike the antigen not
to mention that it also acts like a
estrogen in the body too so you could
have like a problem with estrogen and
androgens and that's why this has also
been linked to tumors okay in different
parts of your body including your
thyroid so you could have all these mix
things you can have acne receding hair
facial hair a little goiter a little
nodule in your thyroid and you can have
a mixed situation from these chemicals
that are kind of hidden in the
background so PCOS is high antigens this
is one cause a backup of androgens
because this is not converting because
something is blocking it another cause
would be high insulin from eating too
much sugar and then it's triggering a
higher level of what's called IGF here's
another video I did on blood sugars you
can watch that but basically IGF is
called insulin like growth factor which
is a hormone made by the liver that
helps you regulate sugars when you're
not eating
so insulin regulate triggers when you're
eating this regulate sugars when you're
not eating and so when you have too much
insulin you're going to have a spike of
this and this is the one that converts
to androgens okay so that's cause number
two cause number three is not only does
the ovary make androgen some and a
female but the adrenal also makes
antigen to so an overactive adrenal will
produce more androgens from stress and
that's another source so simply speaking
we have an excess of stress and excess
of sugar and GMO chemical foods is the
root cause of this now it makes a lot of
sense because we're looking at it from
the most obvious standpoint not some
mysterious unknown cause so hope you
enjoy the video and I will see you in
the next one